start with one
thing if you're creating a new business
and you've got all these ideas for what
you want to do and and the technology
you want to introduce and all the
products and features of your
of your service that you want to get out
there start with
one thing keep it simple because what
ends up happening
is entrepreneurs we're dreamers right
we're visionaries we see the big picture
we
have a vision for the world of how we
want to build our company
and what place it's going to have in
that world the great things we're going
to do with our companies and how it's
going to change the world right you have
that vision
and yet at the same time you're still
one person haven't even started yet
and often all of those ideas
become this avalanche of work and so
many decisions that have to be made
that you don't end up doing anything
enough sticking at your job you have no
momentum with your company because
you get overwhelmed and you don't know
where to start
with one thing have one thing that
you're really good at
that you're going to become the best in
the world at hone in on that skill
and get known for that and everything
else will develop from there
you don't have to have the whole thing
planned out from the start but you have
to start
so keep it simple and pick one thing
that you can focus on
this is all in response to a question i
got on youtube i love you guys
uh drew i love drew so drew
writes in wow can't believe i'm posting
my first
youtube comment ever this is my first
one so welcome
drew congrats on popping the youtube
cherry
he writes in basically he wants to start
a clothing e-commerce company
okay and he's had all these questions
how to use wordpress
how to do e-commerce should i find a
supplier from the beginning
how do i make sure they're responsible
and reputable
all of these questions about how to
start this business the most important
sentence that drew wrote in his
statement here let me find it
he said i really like fashion and style
in general but
i'd like people to be stylish without
having to spend
thousands of pounds he's in the uk so
pounds so pounds could be dollars
euros whatever he'd like people to be
stylish
without having to spend thousands of
dollars
that's something that people can twig to
and that's something that drew
can become one of the best in the world
at that's something that people
understand everybody wants to look good
and they don't want to spend a lot of
money doing it
you can help so get started and don't
get worried about the e-commerce and the
wordpress
and teaching yourself something that
you're not good at and making the deals
with the suppliers
it will come but you have to get started
on the one thing that you're really good
at
and stop doing the stuff that you suck
at start on facebook
you can use facebook start posting tips
start posting news or posting
information things that mean something
to you
tips that you think can really help
people you're not selling something
you're providing value you're building
an audience you're creating a movement
and from there you can get people on a
newsletter list you can send them
a weekly newsletter that's giving them
value-add information
and if you discover products that you
like and there's an affiliate program
for you can sign up for it
and every sale that's made you're gonna
get a cut of that but you're only
promoting things that you firmly believe
in
start the movement if you can start this
up if you can
build it up on facebook to start and
just get people
following you and listening to you and
commenting on the stuff you're saying
opportunities will open up for you okay
it's a little it's not concrete
it's not tangible but this starting with
business is not always concrete right
the vision is going to change
right as you get through this how how
you make this company happen
is going to change what you end up
selling is going to change
that applies to every business when i
first started my company this business
right now of helping
entrepreneurs when i started doing that
i had no idea how i was going to make
money
i didn't even do it to make money i did
it because i felt it was needed i felt
like i didn't have anybody to help me
along my path and i struggled and i
almost quit and i almost gave up
multiple times and i wished somebody
made these kinds of videos and answered
my questions
to help me get to where i needed to go i
almost
i almost failed tons of times
and i made it through and that's why i
started this that's why i started doing
these videos for you guys
and as a result i've built a movement
and people are interested and people
watch every video and they leave
comments
and they they follow me on twitter and
they respond to stuff and they sign up
for my newsletter
and from that companies approach me
microsoft and google and hp and dell and
wells fargo and
just the list goes on and on home depot
contacted me we want to do something
together home depot
it comes because i have momentum
and i would never have thought hey i'm
going to go reach out to home depot
and review one of their products and
promote that on my website
i would never would never thought like i
it's
too far out of the realm of possibility
of what i thought was was gonna happen
but it happened things happened for me
because i spent so much time
investing into my community and building
this movement up
so you can build something similar it's
not an entrepreneurship but you're
helping people
become stylish become trendy on a budget
you're that guy when people are thinking
about who do i turn to for fashion
advice that's not going to cost me an
arm and a leg
your name should come up if you are on
the tip of everybody's tongue
around that topic then companies will
find you and say hey can we
work together can we find something to
do together but
none of that happens until you go until
you start until you get momentum
so don't let your lack of knowledge
around wordpress or e-commerce or
negotiating deals or any of that don't
let any of that stuff
hold you back from starting this
business
from starting your movement because it's
important because
you can have such a great impact on this
world and feel
like you're doing something meaningful
and from there if you keep pouring
yourself into it
opportunities will open themselves up to
you and you may not even need to know
wordpress or e-commerce something new
and amazing may come along and it will
focus on one thing be the best in the
world at it and get
started don't delay believe
for those of you watching like the video
please give it a thumbs up below i love
seeing those come in and let me know
what you think
give me your thoughts leave a comment
underneath you have a question for me
leave it below you could be like drew
have your first
first comment ever on youtube and i'll
make a response for you thank you so
much and i'll see you soon
you